the Joe Rogan experience and then you
want to get guns alright let me ask you
a slightly different question it's
actually totally different question as
I'm sure you know if you look at any
indicator of like prosperity longevity
health literacy access to food etc
humankind is way better off than it's
ever been
yes-no without question on average
there's still a lot of people with a lot
of trouble there's still parts of the
world that are still in bad shape and so
it's trending in an amazing amazing
direction
why are we so unhappy I don't think we
know how to manage our life correctly in
life doesn't come with a guidebook
it doesn't come with when you're in this
condition seek out these remedies start
exercising get together with your
friends tell them you love them meet up
and have dinner and hug each other
sleep well sleep well drink water you
know there's an whiskey a little bit of
whiskey too right and also you know so
many of us have a bad head start like
you're starting off you know like how
about your dad
he'd been growing up getting kicked out
of the family yeah I mean and then
starts a family of his own well you
don't even know your grandfather I mean
it's madness right madness so you're
you're coming out of this stressful
pocket or maybe your dad goes to jail or
maybe your your mom dies when you're
young all these things that happen to
people were they have this bad start
right and then they develop defense
mechanisms to deal with other
insecurities and they get around similar
minded people and you curse the world
and [ __ ] everybody and [ __ ] the police
and [ __ ] through this and then you get
in these communities of people that
think the same way and then maybe
there's gangs and maybe there's drugs
and maybe there's crime and despair and
sadness and it may be just negative
people maybe there's none of the above
maybe there's no danger it's just
[ __ ] annoying every day people
complaining about [ __ ] and you're stuck
in the mud of humanity with people it's
real hard to engineer 350 million people
out of that but for yourself you can
take actions to make your life better
and if everybody did that if everybody
took actions to make their life a
happier experience by doing those things
by exercising eating well hugging
friends in an enhancing community just
try to be nicer to people everybody that
would be a massive [ __ ] so let me ask
you this I feel like the list you just
gave is basically my list to write I try
that's what I try to do pretty much and
they all sound attractive yes so why is
it so hard for so many people to do it
because people are lazy and the reason
why we're lazy is because it's very
difficult for us to waste resources on
something that we don't currently do and
even though we know something to be true
that if you do this well the long-term
benefits are that but short terms like I
want to do it right now right because
your body like craves relaxation because
it used to be a very rare thing to
achieve all right so if you could pick
one thing let's say let's say I'm a why
would I pick one thing well the first
thing it would say the first thing let's
say let's say that I feel like you know
what society says everything's great I'm
unhappy financially okay why is exercise
the one because your blood pumping right
release natural endorphins and you
legitimately feel better I know I also
think of the I think about this all the
time I think of your body as almost like
the energy in your body is like a
battery and it requires a certain amount
of use and when you don't use it it
overflows and then you get weird
behavior and overreacting to things and
you almost like get antsy you got to get
up and move cognitively it's a big I
find what do you do with let's say you
have to take two long flights let's say
you're unable to exercise for like you
know 24 36 hours you're fine you don't
have no I mean you you know you don't
know many days off yeah yeah that's fine
mmm it's fine the whole key is just to
develop regular habits if you have to
take two or three days off it doesn't
matter the whole key is just regular
habits what's your sleep regime oh yeah
tells me every night how much I sleep
yeah and how has it improved it has the
feedback improved your sleep because it
may be accountable yeah like I was like
I get like seven eight hours every night
and I was getting like four and five and
I was like oh you lying [ __ ] so it may
be it may be concentrate more on getting
what you do to sleep better or sleep
well it's just a matter of the time it's
my one did you change like do you sleep
with earplugs and I mask anything like I
don't have a problem sleeping okay sleep
well you just problem is
doing things and waking up early and I
realize like okay if I'm gonna wake up
that early I got to go to bed early yeah
I really need to you're not a Napper no
I don't know no gum um I just never
enjoy it really yeah you never tried it
no I have no but doesn't work like when
I'm done I'm done
do you drink caffeine yes have you ever
tried the caffeine nap do you know about
yes yes and yeah I know what it so you
that's not my problem all right my
problem is when I'm off when I shut down
I shut down say what 20 minute nap
becomes eight hours it's not interested
my god I mean the horse I don't mean to
criticize your no you're plenty
productive lately but there's a balance
there's a balance between being
productive and being happy right and I
think it's hard to find that balance
because we look at like the the numbers
that come in whether it's money or
productivity or you know the number of
things you've been able to create and
you think of that as being like but look
I can get so much done but if you maybe
got less of those numbers but more of
the numbers in terms of the amount of
sleep you got you would enjoy the whole
overall experience more I worry that uh
I think for a lot of people who are
successful in different realms could be
sports businesses entertainment whatever
success is intoxicating yes and then you
want more event right and then it
becomes very easy to see that as the
main goal at the expense of loved ones
other people I'm looking for I'd like to
know how and I know some people do
manage that really well and I know some
incredibly successful people are
incredibly generous in spirit to people
around them but I find that's pretty
rare I find that success often is driven
by a sort of ambition that's a little
bit unseemly and I'd like to know how to
deal with that a little bit but it
doesn't have to be but it seems like it
would be if it's a number game right if
success meaning like you're in a
business you're trying to sell the most
placards or whatever like whatever it is
you know you have this thing in your
head and like you're really driven just
like you're selling placards you're
already starting behind ok widgets
alright you're selling the most widgets
and you you have this goal in your mind
at being number one and you're obsessed
and you know and everyone's going to
tell your story Oh Bob he wouldn't
go every time I got there he was in the
office and he left after everybody but
look now Bob's got a [ __ ] yacht and
he's also got a pacemaker right and
Bob's ready to take over any minute now
but also I think the thing is in pursuit
of success I think what often happens
that I've seen in people I know and in
people I don't know but I've read about
is that your moral compass starts to
shift now you're willing it's not
necessarily true there's a lot of people
that are successful and we were only
talking about business right we're not
about athletics are we I'm talking about
thinking of some people in academia who
you know even though the average person
may not consider the stakes in academia
super high but like if you get in a big
university department and you start to
write papers and get published and then
get grants and accolades and so on
you're on a trajectory that's very
intoxicating and then all of a sudden I
think it's uh it's more I think it's
tempting or not even tempting I don't
think it's even a conscious decision you
start to make decisions that are not as
sound not as morally acceptable as you
would have made five years ago when you
were starting out and I don't like I see
that happening a lot I see it in media I
see people cutting corners I see it in
business
[Applause]